oui il ya le problème de ce qu'il a dit
il ya le problème de l'effet de ce qu'il
a dit il c'est vrai que politiquement on
a beaucoup c'est quand même pas
formidable c'est être là parce que c'est
ce que dit si ce qui fait la ligue
aurait un problème c'est quand même pas
la première fois il l'a une habitude ici
et ça va quand même toujours un peu dans
les deux sens et que c'est une parole de
vérité qui consiste toujours à dire que
assemble de gens ne font pas ce qu'il
faut et c'est quand même jour une parole
qui va du haut vers le bas et une parole
je n'ai pas forcément mais présente mais
en tout cas qu'ils condamnent est qui et
qui dit bon c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire
il ya eu la sphère des illettrés dans
l'histoire de gad rappelez vous c'était
en 2014
il ya eu en 2015 ils les français
doivent de tous devenir milliardaire
c'est très sympathique près tout
pourquoi mais il ya des gens qui disent
bon ben il est bien gentil mais moi je
ne peux pas je n'arrive pas en 2016 le
costard tac apple [ __ ] il vaut mieux
travailler pour que pour te payer c'est
vrai aussi mais c'est bon il ya eu
quelques cas d'autres les gares les
fainéants les gars on croise des gens
qui ne sont rien ce soir donc si on met
boutoute bout à bout toutes ces petites
phrases ça dessine comme un paysage
psychologique qui même si phrase après
phrase semble de gens disent web et la
région ont dit ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils
créent une image de deux distances de
supériorité je suis pas tant que ça du
mépris de classe il ya surtout souvent
un côté technocratique
moi je sais ce qu'il faut faire c'est
tellement mais c'est tellement simple y
a qu'à le faire il ya des emplois non
pourvus mais allez-y les emplois non
plus ça c'est quand même facile à dire
quand on est du bon côté ce que nous
sommes les uns et les autres pour les
gens qui perçoivent ça une partie ils le
ressentent mal